[Musik]
notop am Haushalt wen macht die ampelarm
das ist unser Thema heute und damit
einen guten Abend liebe Zuschauer der
ampelplan ist gescheitert keine Einigung
für den Haushalt
2024 von der größten innenpolitischen
Krise der Regierung spricht spdchef
klingball wenn es denn nur eine Krise
der Ampel wäre längst geht es nicht mehr
nur um 17 oder doch eher 30 Milliarden
auf dem Spiel steht die Glaubwürdigkeit
der drei Koalitionspartner und das
Vertrauen in die Kompetenz der Politik
überhaupt die Ampel hatte sich viel
vorgenommen ist das alles noch zu
schaffen erst recht mit wirklich
angezogener Schuldenbremse wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen der
Generalsekretär der SPD Kevin
küert Ksten Linnemann der
Generalsekretär der
CDU SAR Wagenknecht vom Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht der Ökonom Jens
südekum und die spiegeljournalistin
Melanie
Amann sie sind zu Gast bei mayibritt ner
und die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung ausgesprochen herzlich los
geht's Kevin küert heute kam die
Nachricht keine Einigung bisher morgen
soll weiter verhandelt werden unter den
drei Matadoren woran liegt's geht's in
erster Linie um die Notbremse auch für
2024 ist das das größte Problem es geht
einfach um die Gesamtauflösung man muss
das ja den Leuten noch mal deutlich
machen mit dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vor wenigen
Wochen ist die Grundlage aller Politik
in Deutschland nämlich der öffentliche
Haushalt das womit wir alle Vorhaben
finanzieren um einen großen
Milliardenbetrag reduziert worden und
dieses 17 oder 30 17 oder 30 Christian
Lindner sagt 16,9 Milliarden aber
eigentlich kommen die 14 aus dem KTF ja
noch mit dazu so würde ich auch rechnen
denn das alles bezieht sich auf Vorhaben
die die Ampel gemeinsam gemacht hat
insofern alleine fürs nächste Jahr um
und bei 30 Milliarden und man muss der
transparenzhalber dazu sagen es wird ja
in den Jahren da drauf mehr wir reden ja
nicht nur überers nächste Jahr sondern
auf die gesamten nächsten Jahre und
deswegen ist das keine kleine Operation
die da im Moment stattfindet sondern
eine ganz große wir haben das Bestreben
so schnell wie möglich fertig zu werden
auch dieses Jahr noch eine politische
Einigung zu haben aber jetzt mit dem
heutigen Tag ist klar vom zeitlichen
Rahmen her gibt es jetzt keine Abläufe
mehr die uns noch vor Weihnachten zu
einem Beschluss des Haushalts 24 bringen
und daher heute die Feststellung dass
damit eben nicht mehr gerechnet werden
kann zu rechnen ist
2024 noch mal eine Notlage das wünschen
sich die Grünen und die SPD Herr Lindner
ist davon nicht nur nicht überzeugt
sondern er sagt Sätze wie die und zwar
unentwegt dass eigentlich genug Geld da
ist wir haben genug Geld der Appetit
nach immer mehr Geld ist für mich
verstörend wir müssen mit dem Geld das
wir haben nur besser
umgehen ja wie kann man in eine Notlage
2024 erklären wenn der
Bundesfinanzminister die ganze Zeit sagt
wir haben eigentlich kein Geldproblem
ich werde die Verhandlung über den
Haushalt jetzt nicht ins Fernsehen
verlagern aber ich möchte einfach in der
Sache sagen warum wir da einen anderen
Standpunkt haben die Lücke die da in den
Haushalt jetzt reingerissen wurde ist ja
in einer Größenordnung da geht's ja
nicht um ein paar Briefbeschwerer die
für Büros des öffentlichen Dienstes
gekauft werden sollte sondern das ist
eine Größenordnung da müssen Sie wie Sie
es auch drehen und wenden vor allem die
Investitionstätigkeit des Staates
zurückfahren und das sind wir nicht
bereit zu tun hier geht es nicht darum
irgendwelche zusatzprojekte oder über
den rekordbeschäftigten Stand in
Deutschland hinaus irgendwas was noch
eine halbe Million Arbeitsplätze schafft
zu finanzieren sondern hier geht's um
Investitionen die den Kern die Substanz
der Volkswirtschaft in Deutschland unser
industrielles Rückgrad bewahren sollen
dass hier in den nächsten 10 20 30
Jahren industriell was produziert wird
da hängen Beschäftigte dran deren
Einkommen da häen ganze Familien und
Regionen dran um die kämpfen wir nicht
um eine Milliarde links oder rechts im
Haushalt sondern darum ob dieser Staat
ein aktiver ein investierender Staat
sein kann in den nächsten Jahren und
deshalb machen wir es uns auch nicht
leicht in den Verhandlungen Stagen
schlagen und nicht beim erstbesten
Angebot ein weil es um so viel geht und
dann ist trotzdem die Frage wo und an
welcher Stelle kann gespart werden
Melanie Ammann ist bei uns
stellvertretende Chefredakteurin des
Spiegels Frau Amann ein sogenannter
shutdown wie in den USA steht nicht zu
befürchten in diesem Land auch das sagt
Christian Lindner unentwegt und der
Bundeskanzler auch
was wäre also so schlimm dar wenn der
Haushalt im nächsten Jahr für das
nächste Jahr kommt und nicht heute auf
dem Papier geht es nur um ein paar
Wochen und der küer hat ja auch ein
bisschen versucht es so auf die formelle
Ebene zu ziehen aber es ist natürlich
schon ein Fiasko dass diese Unsicherheit
jetzt noch weiter besteht und dass das
Stichwort kämpfen dass sie verwendet hab
fand ich auch interessant es ist halt
offensichtlich keine politische Einigung
möglich zwischen nur drei Personen den
drei entscheidenden Personen der Ampel
das heißt es ist nach wie vor unklar
diese drei Leute diese treuka mich
erinnert das ein bisschen an die Zeit
der Eurorettung als einmal die treuka
eingeritten kam also auch diese drei
können sich nicht einigen auf einen
gemeinsamen Kurs und dass das da hätte
Herr habbeck ja auch nach Dubai fahren
können also wenn das offensichtlich so
komplex ist und so lange dauert und
insofern ist das diese Unsicherheit die
davon ausgeht für die Unternehmen und
auch für die Leute denen der
Bundeskanzler noch gesagt hat es ändert
sich für euch nichts keine Angst wollte
ich gerade sagen der jetzt kommt gerade
das ist ein riesen Milliardenloch wir
kämpfen um die Zukunft des Landes so
ungefähr
also da ist schon ein gewisser
Widerspruch aber nicht um die Renten
oder wohngelder oder barfökzahlung der
Menschen das ist ja das was der
Bundeskanzler im Bundestag adressiert
hat weil viele Leute ja nicht so tief in
den Details drin sind und denken es ist
jetzt wie in den USA wir sind vor einem
shutdown und morgen werden die Gehälter
der Beamten nicht mehr bezahlt ich
glaube hier müssen alle Akteuren
Interesse daran haben dass wir die
Sachen gerade und korrekt darstellen
aber viel mehr ja auch nicht wenn ich
das kurz sagen darf also ist wirklich so
das absolut verpflichtende da haben Sie
Recht das wird weiter ausgezahlt aber
für jede weitere Ausgabe für jede
weitere größere Invest
sitzt Herr Lindner da und sagt Ja oder
Nein muss der Minister oder die
Ministerin zu ihm kommen und darum
bitten und und deswegen stehen halt auch
Dinge auf der Kippe die über jetzt
normale Rentenzahlung oder so
hinausgehen ja das heißt Herr Lindner
hat jetzt auch tatsächlich mehr macht
weil er entscheiden wird genau wie
Melanie Ammann sagt was überhaupt noch
von dieser Regierung kommt bis man sich
geeinigt hat um es ganz klar zu sagen
bei allen Differenzen in der Sache ich
bin überzeugt dass auch chrisan Lindner
mit uns eine Ergebnis erzielen möchte
über den Haushalt 24 g na ja vielleicht
glaubt man es ja mehr wenn ich es dann
einfach ausspreche als Generalsekretär
der SPD ich glaube nicht dass er jetzt
auf Zeit spielt um möglichst spät im
nächsten Jahr ein Haushaltsbeschluss
herbeizuführen damit wir lange in der
vorläufigen Haushaltsführung sind
sondern unser Eindruck ist schon auch
die Liberalen wollen dass wir möglichst
zügig zu einem Haushalt kommen aber es
ist in dieser Koalition wie es da gebe
ich in Brief und Siegel drauf in jeder
Koalition wäre wenn sie kurz vor
Jahresende in ein stehenden Haushalt der
schon aufgestellt ist ein Loch in dieser
Größenordnung reinschneiden dann wird es
keine Koalition der Welt geben die nach
zwei Tagen sagt wir haben eine andere
Lösung dafür gefunden sondern dann macht
das große Denksport Karsten Lindemann
ist bei uns Generalsekretär der CDU Herr
Lindemann die FDP sagt genau das besser
gründlich als jetzt zu
schnell da müssen Sie zustimmen man hat
ja Zeit gehabt monatelang man wusste ja
dass das Urteil vor 22 Tagen alle
Experten haben darauf hingewiesen dass
es wahrscheinlich ist dass das Urteil so
kommt wie es kommt jetzt haben wir Tag
22 Nacht dem Urteil dieses Land ist
völlig verunsichert ich spreche jeden
Tag mit Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Unternehmern viele sind fassungslos weil
es keinen Plan gibt kein Ziel gibt keine
Zukunft gibt und jetzt gehen wir über
die Jahreswende ins Jahr 24 mit wenig
Hoffnung und ich finde das ganze
disaster zeigt dass diese Ampelkoalition
nie ein gemeinsames Fundament hatte man
hat das mit Geld zusammengehalten es gab
nie eine gemeinsame Erzählung für die
Zukunft dieses Landes und danach sehen
sich die Menschen nach Führung und
Orientierung und der Bundeskanzler zeigt
das einfach nicht er hat eine Rede
gehalten im Deutschen Bundestag und man
weiß nachher nicht mehr als vorher und
deshalb ich sag das mal ganz offen ich
glaube es wäre besser dass der
Bundeskanzler die Vertrauensfrage stellt
im Deutschen Bundestag und wenn er die
gewinnt dann Plan machen für die
nächsten Z Jahre und können gerne
Neuanfang machen so wie jetzt darf es
nicht weitergehen wenn er die verliert
muss der Bürger entscheiden die
bürgerinn und Bürger müssen entscheiden
per Neuwahl ich glaube wir brauchen
jetzt mal Ehrlichkeit und Klarheit zi
Jahre so weitermachen kann sich dieses
Land nicht leisten Herr küer dann sind
sie schon wieder dran Vertrauensfrage im
Parlament möglichst bald damit man 14%
für die SPD damit man den
Vertrauensverlust auch bei den Bürgern
überhaupt zu dieser Regierung im
Parlament nachfragt ich bin mir absolut
sicher dass der Bundeskanzler das
Vertrauen aller Teile der Koalition
genießt aber ich will sie auch beim Wort
nehmen sie haben jetzt eingangs ihre
Statements gesagt sie sprechen mit
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wie wir alle und
mit Unternehmen und Verunsicherung ist
mit Händen greifbar würde ich übrigens
bestätigen weil natürlich ist das eine
schwierige Situation im Moment wer würde
denn was anderes behaupten wollen aber
die Antwort daruf um jetzt mehr Halt und
Sicherheit zu geben kann auch nicht sein
dass wir jetzt aus dem Bundestag eine
Fußballarena machen ein Spiel
durchführen dann vielleicht zu Neuwahlen
das haben sie ja gerade nahgelegt
bekommen dann wird ja monatelang weiter
gar nichts gemacht was löst sich denn
für einen Unternehmer der jetzt auf
Planungssicherheit setzt für eine
Investition für eine beihilfefrage was
löst sich denn an dessen Unsicherheiten
wenn Deutschland jetzt in Neuwahlen
geschickt wird er K kte vielleicht mal
eine andere Politik gemacht werden in
Deutschland also es ist ja schon ein wer
auch ordentlich begrüßt sie sind neue
Vorsitzende einer Bewegung die ihren
Namen trägt und bezeichnen diese
Regierung als die schlechteste die es in
Deutschland wahrscheinlich gegeben hat
kleine Frage vorne weg äh mit den mit
der Konfrontation Klimawandel mit der
Energiekrise mit den Kriegen die es gibt
in der Welt würden Sie konzidieren dass
diese ampelregierung tatsächlich auch
vor besonderen Aufgaben stand ja
natürlich ist das weltpolitische um um
die Umgebung schwierig und natürlich
gibt es da Herausforderung nur die
weltpolitische Lage ist für andere
Länder auch schwierig und wir sind
Schlusslicht wir stehen ganz hinten
unter den Industrieländern wir haben in
diesem Jahr als einzige oder eines der
ganz wenigen eine schrumpfende
Wirtschaft die Prognosen fürs nächste
Jahr sind schon wieder nach unten
revidiert worden das war sogar schon
bevor diese ganze das ganze disaster
jetzt mit den Schattenhaushalten und mit
dem Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts kam
und das Problem ist ja tatsächlich diese
drei ampelparteien die haben sich in
ihren Ideologien eingegraben da ist kein
gemeinsamer Plan aber ehrlich gesagt das
hörte sich ja schön an Herr Lindemann
was sie jetzt hier erzählt haben also
wenn ich an März höre beispielsweise
auch in der letzten Haushaltsdebatte
oder auch jetzt im Bundestag also was
ist denn da der Plan also da war der
Plan also irgendwie die Rentner kriegen
noch zu viel Geld die armen Kinder
kriegen noch zu viel Geld und für
Rüstung sollte eigentlich noch mehr
ausgegeben werden also wenn das der Plan
der CDU ist dann wird in diesem Land
auch nicht nicht gesprochen über Rüstung
hat er nicht
gesprochen sie sitzen hier fraktionslos
parteilos sie haben noch niemals ein
Programm und wollen jetzt Herr Merz
sagen worüber er gesprochen ich weiß gar
nicht worüber
sie die diesem Land mal wieder
Orientierung gegeben hat sie vielleicht
ich glaube dass es ganz viele Menschen
in Deutschland gibt die sich jetzt schon
wünschen dass ich die Politik verändert
weil es einfach so nicht weitergehen
kann und wie gesagt auch die
Verunsicherung die war doch vorher schon
da wir haben doch eine wirklich eine
schwierige wirtschaftliche Situation
weil die viele Unternehmen mit den hohen
Energiepreisen nicht zu Rande kommen
viele Menschen auch nicht mehr wissen
wie sie über den Monat kommen die Löhne
sind jetzt seit 3 Jahren immer wieder
gesunken und natürlich ist das ganz
schwierig und die Ampel des diskutiert
darüber ob man beim Bürgergeld kürzt
oder Sie haben ja auch noch mal das
angesprochen oder ob man vielleicht auch
bei den Renten kürzen soll und sie
würden es alles anders machen wir reden
darüber was Sie anders machen würden wir
wollen unbedingt auch Jens wüdekum
vorstellen von der Uni Düsseldorf sie
sind Mitglied im Beirat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums Herr
südikum und waren übrigens auch in
karlsrohe bei der Verkündung des
Urteils würden Sie denn auch sagen dass
eigentlich absehbar war dass dieses
Urteil gefällt wurde und dass es diese
Herze gefällt werden würde nein das war
nicht absehbar ich habe damit nicht
gerechnet auch die klegerseite und deren
Vertreter haben nicht damit gerechnet
dass das
wenn man ehrlich ist es haben alle damit
gerechnet dass ein Urteil fallen könnte
wo es heißt in Zukunft müsst ihr in
Notfallsituation so und so agieren weil
das war das erste Mal das war ja das
erste Mal dass die Schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt war und es gab sozusagen
keine präzidenzfälle dafür aber dass
jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt
äh knallhart ähm dieser
Nachtragshaushalt 21 war
verfassungswidrig und es müssen jetzt
sofort 60 Milliarden die eigentlich
verplant waren sind jetzt nichtig und
fallen weg das ist das maximal strengste
Urteil damit hat ehrlich gesagt niemand
gerechnet und es ist auch insofern was
neues weil normalerweise bei so
gewichtigen Entscheidung das
Verfassungsgericht typischerweise den
Gesetzgeber auch Übergangsfristen gibt
und sagt ihr habt jetzt so und so lange
Zeit das ist hier nicht der Fall und
jetzt muss plötzlich das
war am 15 November soll also ein
eigentlich fertiger Haushalt der am Tag
danach in der Bereinigungssitzung quasi
verabschiedet werden sollte soll jetzt
noch kurz vor Weihnachten in der zwei
Wochen sozusagen komplett auf dem Kopf
auf die Füße gestellt werden aus
meericht geht das gar nicht und deswegen
kann aus meiner Sicht eigentlich auch
die vernünftige Reaktion jetzt auf das
Urteil nicht sein dass man jetzt
hektisch irgendwo versucht Geld zusammen
zu kratzen und zu sparen das hat auch
das Verfassungsgericht nicht verlangt
sondern dass jetzt eigentlich die
Konsequenz sein müsste dass man zunächst
erstmal und da kommt diese Notlage 24
ins Spiel sich darüber auch eine gewisse
Zeit verschafft dass man überhaupt
vernünftig auf dieses Urteil reagieren
kann und im nächsten Schritt muss man
auch finde ich in einem großen Konsens
aller Parteien auch darüber nachdenken
was das jetzt bedeutet für die
Fiskalpolitik mittelfristig in
Deutschland wie wir mit der
Schuldenbremse umgehen wollen weil die
maximal scharfgestellte Schuldenbremse
die wir jetzt haben nach dem Urteil ist
aus meiner Sicht ein Korsett mit dem wir
die Aufgaben von die das Land steht
nicht werden bewältigen das heißt sie
sagen es wird gar nicht gelingen zu
kürzen also das was der Finanzminister
jetzt sagt nämlich wir haben ihm ja
zugehört man muss eigentlich nur noch
mal durch alle Position durchgehen und
wir werden diese 17 Milliarden schon
finden das was der Bundesfinanzminister
sagt ziehen sie in Zweifel Herr sü
natürlich kann man rechterisch dieses
Geld finden man kann natürlich irgendwo
kürzen nicht 17 sonder 30 Milliarden ja
aber was heißt das 30 Milliarden das ist
ein sehr sehr großer Betrag das sind
ungefähr 1hal% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts
wenn man jetzt bzw das wären die 60
Entschuldigung 0,75% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts wenn man das jetzt
auf ein Schlag kürzt hat das massive
makroökonomische Konsequenzen wir sind
ja einer Rezession in Deutschland wir
hatten gehofft dass im nächsten Jahr wir
eine leichte Erholung bekommen nicht
spektakulär aber zumindest mal
Wachstumsraten so 0,5 0,7 %. wenn jetzt
diese Kürzung so Knaller durchgezogen
wird wird es das nicht geben dann wird
die Rezession in Deutschland bleiben
wird sich verschärfen verlängern noch
dramatischer die Investitionen werden
noch stärker einbrechen es gibt jetzt
Studien die sagen dass die Investitionen
um 4% Punkte nach unten gehen werden
wenn wir jetzt diese Kürzungspolitik
machen aber so pauschal Ken Sie das doch
gar nicht sagen wenn Sie nicht wissen wo
gekürzt wird oder das finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen schwierig
einfach generell wenn die Summe Weg ist
stirbt die Wirtschaft das also STT aber
es würde eine ernsthafte Rezession die
sich eben dadurch verlänger W das W das
Gegenteil vom ifointitut der sagt ganz
klar die Länder die Schuldenbremsen
haben oder so eine Art gibt ja viele
Schweiz z.B und andere die wachsen viel
schneller weil sie Prioritäten setzen
und sich Konz lvergleich ich rede von
Studien die jetzt versuchen zu
prognostizieren was wären die
Auswirkungen wenn jetzt erstmal der
Betrag der in Rechnung steht die
60 wo sie sparen wenn jetzt die die
Berechnung die dort zu Grunde gelegt
wurde war dass die 60 Milliarden die
eigentlich verplant waren im
klimatransformationsfon KTF dass diese
Investitionen so nicht stattfinden so
gekürzt würden dann würden die
Investition insgesamt gesamtwirtsaftlich
um 4% einbrechen über mehrere Jahre ne
also weil diese 60 Milliarden fallen ja
jetzt nicht 2024 aber es ist ja schon so
es ist ja schon so
dass macht jetzt darüber zu reden ganz
kurze frage ich wollte noch mal auf die
politischen Konsequenzen kommen wir sind
jetzt schon schwer in der
wirtschaftspolitischen Diskussion Frau
Amann Stichwort in welcher Situation
welcher politischen Situation sind wir
jetzt in ihrer Einschätzung glauben Sie
dass diese drei
Matadoren weiter in die verschiedenen
Richtungen strömen werden und es keine
Einigung gibt rechnen Sie damit dass man
sich maximal verbiegt und eine Einigung
finden wird aber ist das dann eine
die noch Vertrauen und Glaubwürdigkeit
finde ja das ist in der Tat die
wichtigere oder schwierigere frage ich
denke schon dass jetzt in den nächsten
Tagen sie wissen da mehr äh ist eine
eine Einigung zwischen diesen dreien und
damit auch einen Kabinettsbeschluss also
die sozusagen politische zurecht Hämmern
des Haushalts gelingen kann das ist das
ist glaube ich und dann ist zumindest
ein bisschen Unsicherheit rausgenommen
wie wie es im nächsten Jahr weitergehen
kann das das ist schon wahr aber ich
meine danach geht es in die Fraktionen
und danach geht es auch in die Details
also es war ja bisher bei der Ampel
meistens so dass es ein im Grundsatz
dann irgendwann nach stundenlanger
Sitzung eine Einigung gab über
schwierige und komplizierte Themen und
sobald es dann um die Umsetzung ging hat
man ja besonders beim
gebäudeenergiegesetz gesehen äh dann auf
einmal verhagte man sich wieder und und
das ist natürlich bei diesen ganzen
Finanzfragen die da dran hängen und den
Auswirkungen in einzelnen Bereichen und
auch die Rückkopplung mit den Parteien
das ist ja dann das Hauptrisiko dass es
noch gibt es muss ja dann auch ein
Koalitionsausschuss geben das heißt die
drei können das da jetzt nicht einfach
äh für alle beschließen die müssen sich
rückkoppeln bei den Grünen ist es
kompliziert weil ja auch dann Herr Habig
eben auch nicht gleich der der
Parteivorsitzende ist und schon gar
nicht Fraktionsvorsitzender bei Herr
Scholz ist auch nicht Parteivorsitzender
wird jetzt am Wochenende vielleicht ein
Antrag von seinem Parteitag kriegen du
darfst aber nicht hier kürzen und du
darfst aber nicht hier kürzen also das
heißt da kommt schon da kommen schon
ganz schön viele HAK ist ein Zeitpunkt
auch aus ihrer Sicht wo sie sagen der
Bundeskanzler sollte die Vertrauensfrage
stellen er recht wenn sich das jetzt
weitere Wochen zieht also mir würde es
reichen wenn er sich überhaupt erstmal
erklären wde also das ist das finde ich
ist man weiß im Moment einfach nicht er
war ja war schon ein paar mal bei ihnen
so im oneonone Interview wo war er jetzt
die ganze Zeit also die
Regierungserklärung war war denkbar
blass man hat das Gefühl er steht selber
so unter Schock das wirkt ja auch als
wäre schon um ein paar Jahre gealtert
wenn man ihn sich so anschaut dasaltiger
sch für ihn es gab keinen Plan B und das
stimmt auch finde ich was der südikum
sagt das war eine Überraschung dieses
Urteil in dieser Härte die man nicht
vorher gesehen hat ich meine wenn man
sieht wie Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel
bei der Eurorettung immer wieder
gut weggekommen ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat da keine
Steine in den Weg gelegt noch nicht mal
bei den Corona Maßnahmen hat es so hart
geurteilt wie jetzt äh und also das war
schon das war schon gewaltiger Schock
aber das hat die gesamte wie soll man
sagen das gesamte politische narrativ
von Olaf Scholz zerstört dieses gesamte
Selbstbild von ihm und auch das
Außenbild das er von sich gezeichnet hat
von dem Mann der eben als ehemaliger
Bundesfinanzminister keiner kann den
Haushalt so gut aufstellen wie er keiner
kennt sich mit den Staatsfinanzen so
excellent aus wie er und ausgchnet er
ist jetzt der Regelbrecher und ich
glaube dieser Schock hat auch dazu
geführt dass er so verstummt ist
irgendwie oder man ihn ja offenbar
regelrecht dazu treiben musste überhaupt
diese Regierungserklärung abzugeben und
mehr da eben nicht gekommen ist außer
vielleicht noch so ein Video auf X oder
so also das ist schon ich finde die
Leute erwarten jetzt in dieser Situation
von ihm einfach Präsenz und eine
Botschaft und eine Beruhigung an eine
Vergewisserung wann wird die kommen Herr
Kü ich habe da eine andere Einschätzung
weil ich glaube dass es unterschiedliche
Erwartung im idealptischen Raum gibt und
bei Bürgerinnen und Bürgern was nicht
heißt dass da nicht eine Verunsicherung
im Moment ist keine Frage aber worüber
hat der Bundeskanzler gesprochen in
seiner Regierungserklärung im Bundestag
er hat die vorhin wiederholte wichtige
Aussage getroffen dass sich die Leute
darauf verlassen können dass die
Rechtsansprüche die sie haben dass
Rentenzahlung geleistet werden können
meh wir gehen hier so dar drüber hinweg
weil in diesen talksh keine Leute sitzen
die im Moment Renten beziehen oder die
auf Wohngeld oder auf barfkleistung
angewiesen sind aber viele Leute Sch
aber das ist doch eine wichtige Klarheit
herzustellen wir hatten voror Frau am
wir hatten vorher kurz vor dieser
Regierungserklärung Äußerung übrigens
aus der Regierung leider heraus vom
Finanzminister die viele Menschen
verunsichert haben in Bezug auf
energiepreisbremsen die zum Jahresende
auslaufen das ist dann relativ ohne
Erklärung so in den öffentlichen Raum
gepostet worden mich haben E-Mails
erreicht ich werde nicht der einzige
gewesen sein Herr küert muss ich das
jetzt eigentlich zurückzahlen was da
gespart worden ist im letzten Jahr das
war doch wichtig das mal auszusprechen
und zu sagen abgesichert für dieses Jahr
aber das betrifft Millionen Menschen
ganz konkret das mag jetzt nicht
Pulitzer Preis verdächtig vorgetragen
gewesen sein geschenkt die Leute kennen
Olaf Scholz jetzt auch schon eine Weile
und wissen dass er jetzt ein
festzeltredner wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
wird aber die politische gesagt Herr K
wir haben das rausgesucht auch letzte
Woche schon eben weil Herr klingball und
sie Herrn Lindner da so beschimpft haben
aber eigentlich hätten sie auch Herr
Scholz beschimpfen müssen er sagte
nämlich wörtlich die Energiepreise
werden absehbar wieder erträglich
deshalb können die preisbremsen
Auslaufen das war seine wörtliche
Formulierung dann ging es weiter wenn
die Situation sich verschärft dann
werden wir natürlich dafür sorgen dass
diese preisbremsen wieder eingeführt
wden absolut und das ist ja eine
wichtige politische Zusicherung denn das
ist die Wiederholung eines Versprechens
aber erstmal laufen sie aus aber es ist
ja die Wiederholung eines Versprechens
eines politischen Versprechens was im
Sommer 2022 als die Energiepreise beim
zehnfachen dessen war was wir heute
haben glücklicherweise was wir heute
haben gewesen sind das nämlich gesagt
wurde für zwei Heizperioden den Winter
22 23 und den jetzt stattfindenden
Winter 23 24 sichern wir zu
übermäßigegweise nicht umgelegt werden
und diese Zusicherung gilt das ist ein
Satz von einer Qualität wie damals von
Merkel und Steinbrück mit den
Spareinlagen die sicher sind
ausgesprochen wurde sind doch ist etwas
worau sich die Menschen verlassen die
Leute doch hauptsächlich verunsichert
ist doch einfach dass sie überhaupt dass
sie spüren die Regierung hat keinen Plan
wo es hingeht also die meisten machen
sich doch einfach sorgen wohin steuert
unser Land weil sie spüren Deutschland
steigt ab wirtschaftlich und zwar ganz
massiv es funktionieren ganz viele Dinge
nicht mehr mein wir haben jetzt diesen
pisatest das deutsche Bildungssystem ist
in einem ziemlich desolaten Zustand wir
haben die Situation Kassenpatienten
warten Monate auf ein Facharzttermin die
Bahn ist nie pünktlich also sind ja ganz
elementare Dinge 700.000 Wohnungen
fehlen und die Regierung hat schon schon
jetzt vor diesem Urteil überhaupt keine
Strategie dafür gehabt jetzt kommt
dieses Urteil dann ist natürlich die
Unsicherheit noch mal größer ich teile
das ja dass die Schuldenbremse in der
jetzigen Form keine kluge Regel ist weil
ich finde und das machen auch die Länder
die erfolgreich sind natürlich muss man
Investitionen anders behandeln als
Konsum Konsumausgaben also jeder
Unternehmer jedes gute Unternehmen
finanziert Investitionen per Kredit und
kritisch wird es wenn er
Dividendenauszahlung oder
aktienrückhäufe per Kredit finanziert
weil dann wird die Substanz des
Unternehmens gepündert aber
Investitionen natürlich kann man per
Kredit finanzieren was ich nicht
verstehe ist warum die Koalition jetzt
nicht die CDU unter Druck setzt die CDU
Landesfürsten die CDU Minister wollen
doch dass finanung weit Linnemann danach
haben wir letzte Woche auch schon
Friedrich März gefragt da ist
tatsächlich bei den Ministerpräsidenten
schon ein ordentliches Türchen geöffnet
und das hören wir uns noch mal an wie
wohl Friedrich Merz sagt dass die
Schuldenbremse eine tolle Sache
ist ich habe eine klare Haltung
die Reform der Schuldenbremse für
Zukunftsinvestitionen ist dringend
erforderlich und die Ministerpräsidenten
von Sachsen und NRW fordern einen
Sparkurs an dessen Ende kann dann ein
Pakt für Deutschland stehen und
vielleicht ein Gespräch über eine
Veränderung der
Schuldenbremse und wenn dann noch was
übrig bleibt und wir kriegen es mit den
Regeln der Schuldenbremse nicht hin dann
kann man sich das
angucken also klingt jetzt nicht mehr
wir sind dagegen und die Schuldenbremse
muss eingehalten werden wird die Politik
in den Ländern gemacht bei den CDU
Ministerpräsidenten oder im Konrad
adenauerhaus die Länder haben ja eine
Schuldenbremse und nutzen sie auch also
beispielsweise schlisswig Holstein der
Kollege Daniel Günther nutzt sie und
setzt sie aus und macht weiter Politik
in der Form wir haben ja eine im Bund
und interessant ist ja wenn ich das
immer höre ja wir müssen investieren wir
müssen Kredite nehmen wir dürfen mit
dieser Schuldenbremse Kredite nehmen 20
Milliarden sogar noch mehr und
Unterehmen unternehmen können auch
Kredite nehmen aber irgendwann ist
Schluss frauwagenknecht und Sie müssen
auch mal die nächsten Generationen
denken als wir die Schuldenbremse noch
nicht hatten als wir die Schuldenbremse
noch nicht hatten wurde das ja versucht
so zu machen mit den Investitionen da
wurden auf einmal Sozialausgaben und
alles wurde auf einmal als Investition
tituliert in Europa wird verhandelt über
den maßrichter Vertrag wie wir mit Geld
umgehen ich möchte nicht noch mal so
eine Staatsschuldenkrise durchmachen
wenn wir jetzt der Vorreiter sind ja und
Verschulden uns als ob es keinen Morgen
gibt werden
gib aber ich finde wirklich also was sie
jetzt hier machen das ist ein
zusammenmixen das ist einfach billig
natürlich geht es um um Investitionen
z.B in unsere Infrastruktur die ist in
einem desolaten Zustand da muss man auch
ehrlicherweise sagen ist nicht nur die
hampelschuld das hat sie auch geerbt von
Regierung wo die CDU vorne saß die SPD
allerdings auch immer drin war also wir
haben einfach über viele Jahre in
Deutschland massive einen massiven
Mangel an öffentlich Investition wenn
3000 Autobahnbrücken marode sind wenn
das Schienennetz massiven
Investitionsbedarf hat ich meine die
Zugverspätung sind ja nicht weil die
Lockführer nicht fahren wollen das ist
gerade jetzt auch augenblicklich
vielleicht im Streik aber sonst liegt's
ja daran dass hier immer auf die
Substanz gewirtschaftet wurde dass nicht
genug Lehrer da sind das sind doch alles
Dinge wenn man das nicht ändert wo soll
denn Deutschland in 10 Jahren stehen
andere Länder machen uns da was vor die
machen Zukunftsinvestition ganz massiv
und wir fallen immer weiter zurück
früher wurden wir mal bewundert für
unsere Infrastruktur für die pünktlichen
Züge in Deutschland für unser
Bildungssystem für Forschung und
Entwicklung in Deutschland das ist doch
alles jetzt findet
Forschung will jetzt nicht schauen nach
Thüringen wo die Linken regieren wie es
da aussieht und Bildung und
Infrastruktur ich nicht machen aber ich
will will eins sagen das Problem ist
nicht Problem nicht seit paar Wochen das
Problem ist nicht dass wir zu wenig Geld
haben das Problem ist die
Genehmigungsverfahren die Bürokratie die
übergul
das6 wiren von 30 Milliarden können es
machen nicht machen weil die Bedingung
nicht da sind dieses Land muss schneller
werden muss effizienter werden wir
können doch nicht immer mit mehr und
mehr und mehr Geld m doch ein bisschen
an die nächsten Generationen denken sie
können doch nicht nur im Jetzt sein wir
müssen mit dem Geld auskommen was wir
einnehmen wir müssen die Dinge erstmal
erwirtschaften und dann verteilen wir
müssen mal wieder menschenverst aber g
darf ja Schulden machen haben sie gerade
gesagt
also ich frage wirklich
auserkennnisinteresse weil das war finde
ich eben ein neuer Akzent sie haben sich
jetzt auf ihren Parteifreund Herrn Güner
bezogen der hat die Aussetzung der
schulbremse auch fürs nächste Jahr in
Schleswig Holstein mit seiner schwarz
Regierung Gemach hat als Begründung
dafür den ukrainekrieg und die
Auswirkung und Erfordernisse die sich
daraus ergeben genutzt soweit so gut
wäre das jetzt aus ihrer Sicht aus der
der CDU CSU auch für den Bund legitim
das wäre ja neu denn bis vor wenigen
Tagen habe ich noch gehört egal mit
welcher Begründung die Ampel die Notlage
ausrufen würde fürs nächste Jahr sie
würden auf jeden Fall dagegen klagen was
gilt den also erstmal m jetzt
unterscheiden auf der einen Seite geht's
um die Schuldenbremse verändern möchte
ich nicht ich möchte sie so lassen wie
sie ist ja sie wollen sie aber verändern
ich will sie so lassen diese
Schuldenbremse diese Schuldenbremse
erlaut Schulden ja bis zu 20 Milliarden
und ich bin der Meinung dass wenn man
eine Notlage ja definiert dann muss es
ein exogenen Schock geben wie ein Coron
coronakrise Krieg und so weiter gibt es
aber für 2024 nicht in den Ländern ist
die Schuldenbremse anders wird die
anders in schwig Holstein gibt's ein
ukrainekrieg mit Auswirkung aber BU
schauich mal genau die Begründung an in
Schleswig-Holstein das ist eine andere
Begründung als die die sie vorhaben und
deswegen müssen wir an dieser
Schuldenbremse festhalten und wir wir
können uns das doch auch gar nicht warum
reden wir nicht einfach mal
über spannten Zeiten wir haben keine
Krise keine externen Schocks die auf un
das ist doch jetzt eine super Chance um
an die verkrusteten Strukturen zu gehen
beim beim ST der ST wier Funk 30
Milliarden verkrust also beim beim also
jetzt nehmen wir mal das Bürgergeld nur
mal ein einfaches Beispiel wir wen 30
Milliarden kommen dabei rum wir wissen
jetzt seit wenigen Tagen dass es sehr
viele Fälle in Deutschland gibt wo man
Vollzeit arbeitet und weniger hat als
wenn man nicht arbeitet gibt es zwei
Kollegen von ihnen ganze
wissenschaftliche Studien gibt es dazu
und wir sehen in Deutschland dass wir
ein System haben was nicht mehr gerecht
ist es gibt Menschen die können arbeiten
tun es aber nicht lasst uns doch mal das
Bürgergeld so ändern dass es gerecht
wird dass wir uns nur noch auf die
konzentrieren die wirklich Hilfe
bedürfen vielleicht sogar noch mehr als
heute aber bei allen anderen sagen wir
wenn jemand Sozialleistung erhält und
arbeiten kann kann er nicht erwarten
dass andere das für ihn bezahlen und
deshalb muss er arbeiten gehen wenn wir
dieses Mal machen Fördern und Fordern
sind das pro 100.000 bürgergeldempfänger
die in Arbeit gehen das muss doch das
Ziel sein in Arbeit wir brauchen wieder
aufel
s Milen warum zugestim wenn das so ein
Anschlag auf die Staatskassen in
Deutschland ist warum ist das und zwar
ausschließlich mit den Stimmen
möglichesen bundesr und im Bundestag sie
haben sich übrigens damals vor der
Einführung der der bürgergeldreform es
war ja noch irr man muss das den Leuten
ja mal sagen das petito um der Union war
lass doch die Arbeitsmarktreform die
Förderung der Arbeitsmarktintegration
lass uns die rausmachen sondern nur die
Regelsatzerhöhung wegen der Inflation
machen das ist ihr
vorschlagformute ein Jahr später reden
sie ganz anders nee ich mach's ganz kurz
sie haben bei jedem Gesetz wir haben
über 100 mal bei ihnen zugestimmt wir
haben immer die abwegung ändern wir noch
was und stimmen dann zu oder lassen wir
es so und lehnen es ab beim Bürgergeld
wollten sie gar keine Sanktion mehr
zulassen wir haben gesagt wenn sich
jemand nicht an die Regeln hält braucht
es Sanktion wir haben das durchgesetzt
und damit haben wir zugestimmt wir haben
schlimmeres Vers mal ein bisschen zu
Orden Sekunde Sekunde Sekunde wir
wollten noch nicht gleich über das
wollte das aber nicht gern so stehen
lassen was gesagt hat weil ich finde das
ist einfach nicht redlich es ist einfach
nicht redlich was sie machen natürlich
gibt es Missbrauch beim Bürgergeld also
ohne jede Frage also wenn ich mir
angucke dass es bei bestimmten
Flüchtlingsgruppen eine Beschäftigten
Quote von 19% gibt dann frage ich mich
schon also z.B bei geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine ist es so in Niederlanden sind
70% in Beschäftigung in Deutschland sind
in Deutschland sind nein es sind in
Niederlanden 70 in Polen 66 es ist viel
mehr als bei uns ist viel mehr als bei
uns so das heißt natürlich wäre es
sinnvoll genauer hinzugucken wer bekommt
Bürgergeld und was macht er damit aber
die Art wie sie die Debatte führen die
ist unredlich weil sie einfach jeden
bürgergeldempfänger unter
faulheitsverdacht setzen und es gibt ja
z. nur die ausländischen
bürgergeldempfänger nicht auch nicht das
es gibt auch aus der Ukraine Menschen
die jetzt hier die die ihre Heimat
verloren haben die Angehörige verloren
haben die in Deutschland arbeiten
natürlich gibt es das auch aber es gibt
auch das andere nur auch
mter die haben Kinder diezwe einplatz
die würden sofort arbeiten wenn sie ihn
finden aber auch die CDU hat nie auch
nur ein Handschlag dafür gemacht dass
diese Menschen diese Mütter jetzt
wirklich einen kitaitapatz bekommen sie
finden ih nicht so dann biben
sie auf Papier aber
sielü und sie sind nach Minuten
disk
Moment kostet 27 Milliarden und ich will
auch noch was sagen ich finde schon dass
wir die Debatte darüber führen müssen wo
Geld völlig überflüssig ausg ganz kurz
beim Bürgergeld nur damit wir auch
tatsächlich noch mal verstehen und alle
nachvollziehen worüber wir reden wir
sind beim Bürgergeld und fragen uns gibt
es wirklich einen Unterschied zwischen
bürgergeldempfängern Deutschen
bürgergeldempfängern und ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen sie sagen undter hören wir
Ihnen Frau wagnecht jetzt auch noch mal
ein bisschen deutlicher zu dass weil wir
den ukrainen relativ viel Geld geben sie
offensichtlich nicht
arbeiten aber wir sollten schon
hinschauen ob es wirklich Bedürftige
sind die hier Anträge stellen oder
Menschen die das halbe Jahr in der
Westukraine verbringen es ist ja schon
auffällig dass die Erwerbsquote der
Ukrainer in Deutschland nur 19% beträgt
in den Niederlanden sind es über
70% so sie sagen dass die Ukrainer
vielleicht das halbe Jahr in der
Westukraine verbringen haben sie Belege
dafür haben sie zahlen dafür also ich
habe nicht gesagt die Ukrainer sondern
ich habe gesagt dass ein Teil
offensichtlich ja also es gibt ja sag
mal ich weiß aus meiner Heimatstadt da
ist ein Haus gemedet worden da war
keiner da da haben sich die Nachbarn
gewundert warum niemand da ist da waren
die Leute zu ha also in ihre Heimat
gefahren ich weiß auch dass es aus den
Jobcentern immer wieder Beschwerden gibt
dass sie nicht erreichbar sind also dass
Menschen Bürgergeld beziehen und dann
zurück in ihre Heimat geben und es ist
schon so dass dort auch vermögensprüfung
z.B die man Deutschland sehr sehr
akribisch macht offensichtlich nicht so
stattfinden ich will jetzt ja auch
wirklich keine Generalverdacht es gibt
eindeutig Menschen sie setzen die
Menschen natürlich unter den Verdacht
weil sie könnten ja auch sagen wir
machen es den Ukrainern kompliziert weil
wir ihre Abschlüsse nicht anerkennen
oder weil wir sie alle in eine deutschen
nein was mich einfach nur ärgert ist
dass man bei Teilen und bei bestimmten
Gruppen überhaupt nicht hinguckt und
dann macht man eine pauschale Debatte
gegens Bürgergeld gegen die Erhöhung des
Bürgergelds und sagt nicht dazu wen das
alles mit treffen würde wir haben z.B
immer mehr rentnerinn und Rentner die
Fallen in die Grundsicherung wenn das
Bürgergeld wenn die Erhöhung nicht kommt
dann heißt das auch dass diese
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und das sind
oft Menschen die haben ihr Leben lang
geschuftet oder sie haben vielleicht
drei Kinder großgezogen dass deren Geld
sinkt also dass die noch nicht mal das
bisschen Inflationsausgleich kriegen die
gze te ich meine wir haben eine
Gesellschaft wo sich am oberen Ende
immer mehr Reichtum zusammenballt wo
richtig in den letzten Jahren auch noch
mehr Vermögen
entstanden wenn sie mich
jetztter sie sich angucken die reichsten
Menschen in Deutschland haben zusammen
ein Vermögen von
11 Milliarden
5 wenn sie denen eine Abgabe von eine
Solidaritätsabgabe von
5% zumuten würden dann würden sie 55
Milliarden einnehmen also ich meine man
kann ja auch mal über Reichtum reden die
Mittelschicht wird immer stärker
belastet der Normalbürger hat eher eine
Senkung in seinem Lebensstandard hat
immer mehr zu kämpfen ganz oben geht man
nicht ran und man redet immer über die
die sowieso schon ganz unten sind und
ich finde das ist ein gesellschaftliches
Klima das das verrot unsere Gesellschaft
das vergiftet auch wirklich das
Zusammenleben da wird eine Stimmung
gemacht die einfach vergftet doch das
Zusammenleben wenn sie im Prinzip der
Ukraine den ukrainischen Menschen die
aus dem aus Kriegsgebieten geflüchtet
sind pauschal unterstellen die würden
die Hälfte des Jahres das ist doch die
Botschaft die damit verbunden ist das
ist die Methode des Populismus können
Sie wir haben es ja hier vorhin
eingeblendet bekommen und ich finde ich
wundere mich auch sie möchten also dass
die deutschen Behörden bei einem
Menschen aus der Ukraine dann sozusagen
die vermög Lage daheim überprüfen Sie
wollen dass der deutsche Staat der
ohnehin dünn gespannt ist bei seiner
Personaldecke auf gerade auf der
kommunalen Ebene wie sonst was Sie
wollen dass diese Leute jetzt bei jedem
ukrainischen Menschen gucken was hat er
denn zu Hause in Kiev oder was hat er
denn zu Hause in Odessa auf dem
Girokonto oder also das ist doch
Entschuldigung zu machen ich habef
hingesen dass man bei deutschen anders
letztlich es ist letztlich Nationalismus
muss man sagen es ist letztlich eine
Zweiklassengesellschaft für
bürgergeldempfänger das muss man sagen
sie sagen die einenag den einen
unterstellen sie pauschal Faulheit und
die
anderen wollen sie schon schon bisschen
große Töpfe hinstellt und wirklich gar
nicht genau hinguckt wer sich bedient
dann bedienen sich eben auch Menschen
die es nicht brauchen so und
desw von den ukrainischen 19% die hier
arbeiten und die sich hier einbringen
natürlich war alleinerzieh ja vielleicht
genau Alleinerziehende oder
Menschen
gienn es in anderen lern Europa deutlich
höhere gibt also sind die gleichen
Flüchtlinge aus dem gleichen
Land deutlich mehr Beschäftigung Wirich
ein bin bei südekum dass wir über die
haushal reden sollten aber ich finde so
können wir die Leute zu Hause nicht mit
der Information stehen lassen die Zahl
stimmt nur etwa jeder fünfte Ukrainer
der da im Bürgergeld also von den die
sozusagen da sind Arbeiten die anderen
sind im bürgergeldbezug was jetzt
natürlich dazu gesagt werden muss damit
das nicht bei diesen Leuten abgeladen
wird ist dass die politischen Maßgaben
bis vor wenigen Wochen bis das nämlich
geändert wurde so waren in Deutschland
dass wir erstens mindestens 9 Monate
Sperrzeit hatten bevor man Arbeit
aufnehmen konnte und das in Bezug auf
Integrationskurse und damit Spracherwerb
Deutschland vereinfacht gesagt gesagt
hat wir wollen erstmal ein ziemlich
hohes Sprachniveau von euch bevor ihr
auf den Arbeitsmarkt losgelassen werdet
dass das auch begleitend gehen kann dass
man auch halb Tags arbeiten kann und
daneben den Sprach- und Integrationskurs
machen kann das wird jetzt künftig
stärker der Fall sein nutzt aber den
vielen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer nicht
die ja offenkundig im Frühjahr 22
hauptsächlich zu uns gekommen sind und
da ja schon eine Weile da sind das war
mir wichtig dass wir jetzt hier nicht so
tun als würden da hunderttausende
Ukrainer sitzen die sich hier ein
schönes Leben machen die befolgen die
Regeln die Politik hier aufgestellt hat
so weil die halten sich daran dass wir
Ihnen diese Forderungen offeriert haben
zum einen die deutsche Sprache erstmal
mit Zen zu können und zum anderen
nachzuweisen was sie eigentlich können
und ihre Abschlüsse anerkennen was wir
wirklich besprechen müssen und ich
versuch noch mal auch wenn es
anstrengend ist zusammenzufassen kann
man im sozialen sparen Herr südekum in
ihrer aus ihrer wart also das jetzt
ausgerechnet die die ohnehin am
wenigsten haben die Fehler dieser
Regierung ausbaden sollen als erstes
kann man im sozialen
sparen erstmal kann man das nicht so
kurzfristig also deswegen finde ich
diese Debatte sehr merkwürdig wir müssen
über jetzt erstmal den Haushalt 24 reden
und die Konsequenzen aus dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil und da ist aus
meiner Sicht habe ich ja schon gesagt
die einzig wirklich realistische
Variante eben zu sagen wir brauchen
etwas mehr Zeit wir brauchen diese
Notlage auch auf Bundesebene damit wir
eben vernünftig auf dieses
verfassungsrichtsurteilorden wir jetzt
Sekunde jetzt ordnen wir auch noch mal
also
100.000 Arbeitslose in Arbeit und
Asylbewerber Flüchtlinge flüchtende
weniger in Deutschland ändern an der
Haushaltslage überhaupt nichts nicht in
ein nennswerten Ausmaß also die
Vorschläge die da auch da waren also
dass man etwa diese geplante Erhöhung
bei Bürgergeld dass man die jetzt nach
noch versucht zu kassieren das würde so
irgendwas zwischen ein bis 2 Milliarden
bringen maximal und ich meine das wäre
ja Geld wenn das wegfällt dieses Geld
geht doch sofort in den Konsum ja das
ist wird doch sofort ausgegeben im
Einzelhandel das heißt wenn ich das
jetzt Kürze hat auch makroökonomisch
wieder problematische Effekte
langfristig kann man über alles reden
vieles was Karsten lmann gesagt hat da
gehe ich ja mit dass wir Reformen
brauchen um eben mehr Arbeit auch im
Bürgergeld zu ermöglichen da gibt es
jetzt gerade sehr gute Vorschläge auch
vom ifo Institut da geht es aber eben
darum Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten zu
schaffen also gerade die ist das echte
Problem momentan ist es ja so beim
bürgergeldbezug nur die ersten 100 €
kann man sozusagen sofort netto für
brutto behalten danach gibt es eine
sogenannte transferentzugsrate und die
ist sehr hoch ja und da ist ein
schreckliches Wort transferzugr ich ver
mehr ich bekomme nur 30 Cent kann ich
quasi behalten 70 Cent sind weg weil sie
angerechnet werden und dieses Problem
das ist in dieser ganzen Breite dort
extrem verbreiten es gibt dann eben auch
ganz perverse Situationen dass jemand 1
€ brutto mehr verdient und am Ende netto
weniger in der Tasche hat weil er den
Anspruch auf andere sozialverleistung
z.B wohlngeld verliert und dass das so
nicht bleiben kann ist doch völlig klar
da muss man natürlich ran das ist aber
eine andere Art von Reform als jetzt
eben zu sagen wir kürzen da bei den
ernsten und gönnen den ihre 60 € nicht
die sie jetzt bekommen sollen so würde
ich daran gehen und jetzt auch noch mal
genereller gesprochen Karsten Lindemann
hat ja gesagt wir brauchen schnellere
Planungs genehmsverfahren weniger
Bürokratie das ist alles richtig da bin
ich voll dabei ja nur das schließt ja
eben eine Reform der Schuldenbremse die
für investive Zwecke ausgerichtet ist ja
nicht aus es sind doch zwei Seiten
derselben Medaille wir brauchen beides
wir brauchen bessere Prozesse und wir
brauchen aber auch eine verlässliche
Finanzierung von diesen Investitionen
auch über einen langen Zeitraum bis 20
30 darüber hinaus nur so können
Unternehmen Investoren auch die
Planungssicherheit haben zu sagen wir
investieren in Deutschland wir können
nicht uns diesen meärchen hingeben dass
wir einfach nur Politik machen die kein
Geld kostet wir brauchen beides aber hab
ich Sie richtig verstanden dass das was
her Lindemann an Kürzungen vorgeschlagen
hat nach ihrer Rechnung bis zu 2
Milliarden bringen könnte und wir reden
über 17 Milliarden die gespart
werden ja aber der Rest sozusagen die
Differenz sind ja die Projekte die man
finanzieren wollte aber das ist ja nicht
etwas was jetzt als konkretes Loch im im
Haushalt klaff sondern das konkrete Loch
was def da sind 17 Milliarden und der
Rest sind Projekte die man gerne machen
will und ich finde wenn man sagt 17
Milliarden und dann hat man noch und
davon sind zwei schon mal weg das ist ja
jetzt nicht in die Hand gespucht oder
also das ist also es sind schon 30
Milliarden 7 s im Kernhaushalt ungefähr
13 Milliarden die betreffen ja nein es
geht auch um den klimatransformationsf
ungefähr 13 Milliarden hätten in 2024
abfließen sollen für Investitionen und
es ist jetzt fraglich ob das passiert ja
noch mal aber das ist kein Haushaltsloch
über das wir jetzt sprechen doch
natürlich
das abfließen sollen aus dem
klimatransformations aus diesem sonderfü
aus diesem nebenhaushalt wenn man so
will die jetzt vermutlich nicht
abfließen und das sind ja gerade eben
diese zukunfstinvestitionen um die es da
auch geht wo es übrigens politischen
Konsens gibt das ist ja das wo da hat
kürzlicher auch Friedrich März gesagt
auch er ist dafür dass in Dresden oder
in Magdeburg die Investitionen in die
Chipfabriken beispielsweise stattfinden
weil auch er anerkennt den strategischen
langfristigen Nutzen dessen dass wir
hier in einer zentralen Technologie
selber produzieren und uns nicht nur auf
grß es geht nicht nur um das Geld was
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht fließt oder
wir wissen es ja nicht ob es fließt oder
nicht die Verunsicherung als solches das
Unternehmen jetzt gar nicht mehr wissen
was ist eigentlich Sache kriege ich
jetzt die Fördermittel kriege ich sie
nicht und bei den Haushalten ist genauso
Thema Heizungstausch kriege ich jetzt
dieses Förderprogramm auf mit dem ich
eigentlich kalkuliert hab oder nicht das
alleine hat ja dann für sich genommen
dann auch noch mal ganz schädliche
gesamtwirtschaftliche Effekte weil das
ist Gift für Investitionen solche Art
von Vers wenn man in die internationale
Wirtschaftspresse schaut Politik
Schlagzeile herbeifantasierte
Schuldenkrise Economist perverser Akt
der
Selbstbeschädigung wenn wir diese
Schuldenbremse nicht reformieren Frau
Amann wenn man jetzt die internationale
Presse mal so ein bisschen durchblättert
ist man nicht mehr so überzeugt dass
unmittelbar bei dieser schuldenreform zu
bleiben bei dieser Schuldenbremse zu
bleiben so ein toller Weg ist ja das ist
ziemlich einhellig und das sind ja jetzt
nicht gerade irgendwie die marxistischen
Wochenschriften oder so sondern das sind
Horte der
der Wirts des Wirtschaftsliberalismus
diese Redaktion also das ist schon
bezeichnet wie man da von außen sagt so
Leute ihr sterbt in fiskalischer
Schönheit und der W geht eure
Infrastruktur kaput also da gibt
natürlich auch viele andere Zeitungen
könnte ich jetzt nennen die das anders
sehen muss muss man Michael Hüter in
also IW sagt natürlich genau das andere
können wir auch Magazin oder in der
jetzigen Form ist die Schuldenbremse wie
aus der Zeit
gefallen so das ist einer eben immerhin
der Leiter des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft in Köln äh sie haben der das
schon immer gesagt hat nicht nur jetzt
der das schon immer gesagt hat und dann
ist hier die Substanz der Frage äh sie
erinnert ein sie erinnert mich in dieser
Sekunde an Wolfgang Scheuble der
natürlich auch gesagt hat dass die
Schlampigkeit
der Finanzplanung diese Ampel zurecht
bestraft wurde und dass das der CDU
sicherlich nutzen wird aber der vor
ihrer Fraktion auch darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat dass der Spielraum jeder
zukünftigen Regierung auch einer CDU
geführten mit diesem Urteil enorm
eingeschränkt ist ich hoffe zitiere
richtig genau eigentlich haben wir doch
jetzt die Klarheit und Ehrlichkeit die
wir brauchen also in Wahlkämpfen also
diese Regierung hat zu viel versprochen
jetzt kommt das Gericht und sagt ihr
müsst Prioritäten setzen und mit dem
Geld auskommen das hat das Gericht
überhaupt nicht gesagt nein doch Stopp
Stopp Po Politis okay politische
interation das heißt in Zukunft müssen
wir ehrlicher Wahlkämpfe machen das
Problem ist aber wir werden die werden
sich einigen die sitzen Sonntagabend
zusammen gehe ich mal von aus weil
Montag die Sitzung ist immer das gleiche
Schema Sonntagabend Koalitionsausschuss
Montag geht die Sitzungswoche los
Sonntagabend einigt man sich irgendwie
kriegt man das Geld zusammen und ich
sage Ihnen das Kernproblem bleibt der
Kanzler muss die Frage stellen ob er es
kann ich bin nicht mehr der Überzeugung
dass er es kann weil er sich weg als
wären sie es jemals gewesen Herr
Linnemann nein wir wir haben ja ganz am
Anfang als Sie gestartet sind mit der
ukrainekrise haben wir sie unterstützt
es ist einfach so RD Deutschland trennt
heute 80% vertrauen ihm nicht sind nicht
zufrieden 80% solche Werte hatten wir
nie wir haben Verantwortung übernommen
wir hatten 10 Jahre Wachstum wolfgang
schäubl hat die Schuldenbremse nicht nur
nicht eingeführt bzw er hat sogar die
schwarze Null ins Leben gerufen und die
auch gelebt deswegen ist das für uns
eine
D
neinin will nur sagen ich will sagte
gibt
Moment Moment die werden aber jedes Jahr
neu abgerufen hier ist Geld in den
Keller gelegt worden schuldengeld sage
ich mal und das nächste Jahr wieder
rausgeholt das ist was anderes ich will
nur sagen sie werden im Januar hier eine
Sendung haben die Unzufriedenheit ist
groß das ist jetzt so ein kleines Thema
ich sag's noch mal diese Ampel hat kein
gemeinsames Fundament keine Erzählung
und dieses Land darf nicht zwei Jahre so
weitermachen es kann irgendwann
Kipppunkt geben und wenn wir den
überschreiten kommen wir danach nicht
mehr zurück hab das Thema Wirtschaft die
Wirtschaft steht am Abgrund der
Mittelstand die energieintensiven
Unternehmen hauen ab Unternehmer sagen
zu mir das Beste was ich machen konnte
ist mein Laden abzuschließen ich bin
froh dass meine Kinder was anderes
machen wir haben das Thema Migration und
wenn wenn ich da nicht wenn ich da nicht
eine Ampel habe die eine die einen
Fahrplan hat es muss ja keine Vision
sein sondern die dieses Land mitnimmt da
kommt irgendwann ein Punkt da komme ich
nicht mehr zurück und deshalb muss diese
Ampel die grundsätzliche Frage
beantworten hat sie die Kraft dieses
Land zwei Jahre nach vorne zu führen das
kann man mit einer Vertrauensfrage
machen wenn sie gewonnen wird braucht es
einen Plan wenn sie verloren wird da
muss die B zu Beginn der Sendung gesagt
und dann ist aber sie richtig sie machen
Sparvorschläge unter anderem beim
Bürgergeld das hatten wir sie sagen dass
es eine Steuerreform geben soll und
kritisieren die Steuerreform von
Christian Lindner da wird jetzt mit 14
Milliarden insgesamt soll die kalte
Progression bekämpft werden sie sagen
sie kriegen eine Steuerreform für alle
Bürger dieses Landes hin ist das nicht
das eigentliche Problem jeder freut sich
natürlich über eine Steuersenkung aber
dass wir denen die es wirklich brauchen
etwas geben also da sind wir bei dem
Gedanken von FR Wagen genau
bekommen in der letzten Zeit eben eher
die giekannen Vorschläge große
Mehrheiten politisch und hat es zu wenig
politische Entscheidungen gegeben die
tatsächlich die Bedürftigen getroffen
hab genau das ist das Zukunftsthema
schlechtthin sie müssen in einer Krise
für die Schwachen für die Schwachen die
sich nicht selbst helfen können müssen
sie mit voller Wucht da sein wir haben
allein 1,8 Millionen erwerbsgeminderte
in Deutschland sie müssen gleichzeitig
die Krise nutzen um die Reformen zu
machen die es braucht beim Bürgergeld
z.B dass wir sagen dass jemand der
Bürgergeld erhält und arbeiten kann auch
arbeiten gehen muss und alle anderen
brauchen die Unterstützung und drittens
braucht dieses landorientierung bra
dieses Land Orientierung aber aber sie
haben einen Punkt wir können in Zukunft
nicht mehr alle mit Subventionen
vollpumpen sondern wir müssen uns
konzentrieren auf die wirklich
Bedürftigen nehmen Sie mal das nehmen
Sie mal das klimageld nehmen Sie mal das
klimageld 300 € für alle das braucht
niemand hier am Tisch niemand aber es
brauchen die ja auch andere
gaspreisbremse muss man sich auch
überlegen in Zukunft braucht das
wirklich jeder oder nur diejenigen die
es wirklich brauchen ich glaube diese
Denke brauchen das ist ein guter Punkt
weil die Zuschüsse für die E-Auto
Infrastruktur die Zuschüsse für die
Energie also jetzt Gas und
strompreisbremse das hat ja auch jeder
ja beim E-Auto ist das Problem dass wir
uns fokussieren auf das E-Auto ist ein
riesen Fehler schon wieder ein Fehler
riesen ist ein riesen Fehler weil wir
dadurch die Apokalypse kommt sie sind
sich nur noch nicht einig von welcher
Seite sie kommt aber sie kommt auf jeden
Fall Einsatz zum Schluss ich glaube dass
wir in diesem Land mal wieder darüber
reden müssen wie wir Aufbruch und
Erneuerung organisieren dass wir den
Mehltau hier an letgie und pessimism nee
dass wir mal wieder Aufbruch und nicht
immer dieses negative pessimistische das
müssen sie machen selber das
horenario
sorgen mit der Ampel dafür dass dieser
Pessimismus in Deutschland ich glaube
sag mal wir sind uns ja relativ einig
dass die Ampel eine extrem schlechte
Regierung ist ich würde sagen die
schlechteste die die Bundesrepublik
jemals hatte trotzdem muss man sagen
dass was die CDU dagegenetzt D man die
grundlegenden Fehlentscheidung der Ampel
haben sie ja immer mitgetragen sie
tragen mit dass im nächsten Jahr z.B 90
Milliarden alleine für Russland
ausgegeben werden da frage ich mich auch
wieso redet eigentlich keiner darüber 20
Milliarden auffuchs im
Verteidigungshaushalt ich bin auch dafür
dass die Bundeswehr in der Lage ist
unser Land zu verteidigen aber dass man
dafür 90 Milliarden braucht die noch
dazu in extrem
intransparenten Verfahren über den
Tresen gehen wir hatten Malin
Verteidigungshaushalt noch 2018 der war
so bei 40 Milliarden wir haben diesen
dieses Jahr einen der ist nach
natokriterien bei 68 Milliarden nächstes
Jahr 90 Milliarden das sind ihre
aufhüchse das in einer
Situationen aber kein Geld in die Hand
nehmen
nichtgätelle do lie in brüen und Straen
gesagt die BU m untersterden ich will
dass dass die Soldaten warme Socken
haben das wird ja immer gesagt und dass
sie Nachtsichtgeräte haben die
funktionieren aber ich will keine
intransparenten Verträge mit mit der
Rüstungsindustrie wo wir zu irgsinnigen
summen Panzer kaufen Hubschrauber kaufen
die nachher nicht fahren und nicht
fliegen und das ist dann wieder das
Argument dass man noch mehr Geld dafür
ausgibt da ist die CDU aber voll dabei
sie haben auch immer unterstützt diese
völlig ihre Sanktionspolitik ich meine
die Energiepreise so hoch sind hat ja
etwas damit zu tun dass wir uns hier
selber richtig ins Knie schießen seit Z
Jahren das ist doch ein Problem wir
können doch die enerie verzichten wenn
die
Energie wir jetzt nicht auch noch die
große Frage stellen wollen ob das ein
sinnvoller oder nicht sinnvoller Krieg
ist den gegen die Ukraine dafürt es ist
allerdings Frau Amann für diese
Regierung natürlich ein Tabu das erstens
unbedingt in die Verfassung in die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres Landes
gezahlt werden muss und dass es endlich
eine verteidigungsfähige Bundeswehr
braucht und es ist völlig klar dass es
eine Unterstützung für die Ukraine
weitergeben muss sehen sie eine Gefahr
dass das bröckelt ja ich sehe absolut
eine Gefahr dass das bröckelt und da
spielen natürlich Personen wie sie eine
entscheidende Rolle weil entschuldigung
ich fand das jetzt wirklich erhellend
wie sie gerade hier aufgetreten sind
also die Bundeswehr muss gestärkt werden
sie muss finanziert werden aber nicht in
dem Ausmaß also das heißt sie muss in
der Lage Lein unser Land zu verteidigen
jetzt wurde ein erster finanzieller
Beitrag geleistet dass die Bundeswehr in
der Lage ist das Land zu verteidigen
wieder langsam in ein paar Jahren das
ist Frau wagenkncht zu viel und
sozusagen man robt sich an das natoziel
heran sie sind eigentlich gegen die NATO
haben aber glaube ich auch noch nie den
NATO aus tritt gefordert
sicherheitshalber weil dann nämlich
einige Leute in ihrer neuen noch nicht
existierenden Partei total ausflippen
würden also ich habe von ihnen noch nie
irgendwie gehört raus aus der NATO aber
sie sind gegen die NATO also ich finde
das das ist ein Beispiel wie das ist
eine eine populistische Nummer die Sie
hier fahren
und da fragen sich ich es ist doch kein
aber die was bei den Leuten hängen
bleibt ist es gibt irgendwie zu viel
Geld für die bundesfäh und das geht auf
unsere Kosten und der kleine Mann wird
geschröpft deshalb und die ukra li aufen
Haut lien auf der faulen Haut und liegen
uns auf der Tasche und das führt auch
dazu dass der Rückhalt für die Ukraine
bröckelt natürlich weil die Leute sagen
wie lange sollen wir das noch
finanzieren wie lange können wir uns das
noch leisten dass aber Russland mit
seinem Angriffskrieg auch eine Bedrohung
für uns ist auch für natürlich den die
westlichen Demokratien das wird dadurch
natürlich total ignoriert aber bei ihnen
ist das ja ohnehin es gibt einen Punkt
verwang machen wir es doch mal so es
gibt einen Punkt da ist die SPD
offensichtlich nicht nur gefühlt sondern
die facto auf ihrer Seite nämlich die
Steuern zu erhöhen für besonders reiche
und das hat Herr küert von sich aus
jetzt nicht in die Debatte geworfen aber
ich frage noch mal danach mit wel eben
mit welcher ferf glauben Sie dass Sie
das durchbekommen und sehen Sie
irgendeine Chance davon dazu dass es
einen nennenswerten
Beitrag zu zur Auflösung dieser
Haushaltskrise sein wird die Steuern für
die Reichen zu erhöhen in diesem Land
gut dann müssen Sie die Frage
wahrscheinlich eher denjenigen Stellen
wo sie erwartbar davon ausgehen können
dass die in der Regierung nicht ganz so
überzeugt davon sind das sind
insbesondere Liberalen ja bitte dann
Christian Lindner mit seiner großen
Freude auf euren Parteitag hier ist er
super die SPD hat das volle Recht das
ganze Wochenende Steuererhöhungen zu
fordern und zu beschließen weil sie eine
eigenständige Partei ist aber es werden
keine Steuererhöhungen mit der FDP in
dieser Koalition beschlossen werden das
heißt redet ihr nur es wird keine
Steuererhöhung in dieser Koalition geben
das heißt solange Herr Lindner mit Ihnen
gemeinsam regiert wird es keine
Steuererhöhungen geben am Ende werden
wir eine Lösung für die Lücke im
Haushalt finden müssen und
ich werde diesen Konflikt jetzt hier
nicht weiter austragen weil ich glaube
wirklich die Leute haben auch die
Schnauze voll davon dass jeden Tag auf
allen Sendung immer zu hören aber wir
werden uns als SPD ganz grundsätzlich an
diesem Wochenende auf unserem Parteitag
positionieren übrigens auch der
Bundeskanzler mit einer Rede die er da
am Samstag halten wird und es geht ja
grundsätzlich darum zu sagen was hält
man für richtig wir finden es
unplausibel dass bei so großen Löchern
gerade für Investitionen für
Zukunftsfragen in unserer Gesellschaft
sich auch heute Abend wieder ein
erheblicher Teil der Diskussion darum
dreht ob man Menschen die keine Arbeit
gerade haben die vielleicht krank sind
die Transferleistung wegen aufstocken
oder so bekommen ob man den noch 20 €
wegnimmt und dass keiner derselben Leute
auf die Idee kommt einmal darüber
nachzudenken ob ein Land was sich
vergleichbar niedrige Steuern
insbesondere im vermögensbereich in
Deutschland leistet im weltweiten
Vergleich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
Last auf die starken Schultern verteilen
kann durchschnittliche Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland Brutt Vollzeit 50.000 im
Jahr zahlen 20% Einkommenssteuer auf ihr
Einkommen Leute die riesige Unternehmen
vererbt kriegen einfach nur weil sie in
die richtige Blutslinie reingeboren
wurden Zahlen effektiv
2,8% weil leider die letzte
Erbschaftssteuerreform mit der Union zu
einem Schweizer Käse mit großen Löchern
geführt hat das kann man doch mal
zumachen an dieser Stelle da kommen
relevante Beträge rum das stärkt auch
noch das gerechtigkeitsempfind stärkt
dass wir Geld haben um Chancen von
Leuten die nicht in eine reiche Familie
geboren wurden entwickeln zu können und
warum reden wir nicht darüber stärker
Herr Lindner hat darauf keine Lust das
ist okay das muss ich respektieren aber
die Gesellschaft kann ja da drüber
diskutieren und die nächste
Bundestagswahl kommt bestimmt und
vermutlich ist auch dann noch nicht
alles tutti in Deutschland und wir
werden immer noch Lösung brauchen also
lassen wir uns darüber noch mal
diskutieren Problem ist einfach dass das
keiner glaubt ne also sie stellen ja den
Bundeskanzler die SPD regiert jetzt seit
8 ja aber sie regieren jetzt hier
wirklich seit über 20 Jahren mit einer
kurzen Unterbrechung und es war immer
die ganze Zeit so dass der Normalbürger
die Mittelschicht eher stärker belastet
wurde die oben eher weniger deswegen ist
es einfach unglaubwürdig im Übrigen hat
auch Herr Lindner gelogen es stimmt ja
gar nicht dass es keine steuerhöhung
gibt also im nächsten Jahr steigt die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas auf halswärme bei
der Gastronomie es steigt der CO2 Preis
die
mautreform insgesamt Erhöhungen von 23
Milliarden die die bürgerinen und Bürger
und zwar vor allem wieder die mit K und
mitleren Geldbeutel aufbringen müssen
also wenn Lindner überall rumtön keine
Steuererhöhungen entlastet worden zahlen
die EEG Umlage seit dem letzten Jahr
nicht mehr der Mindestlohn ist eingefürt
worden bei dem sie sich Bens be enthten
haben STR noch teurer es wird das Gas
noch gemacht
Entschuldigung letztes J
gewesen Verunsicherung Vau Ammer zu der
natürlich wirklich tatsächlich
beigetragen wird weil man sich überhaupt
keinen Reim darauf machen kann als
normaler Bürger was man im Lichte des
nächsten Jahres eigentlich haben wird
was wird weggenommen was wird an Preisen
steigen welche Situation werde ich rund
um meinen Arbeitsplatz haben das ist
nicht berechenbar für die Bürger in
diesem Land was glauben Sie wie spät
kann man da mit einem Plan um die Ecke
kommen tja also ich finde wenn man die
muss man man einfach so sagen die
Arroganz und die Kälte hört mit der
Lindner über seinen Koalitionspartner
spricht da muss man sich wirklich also
einerseits versteht man dann warum die
Einigung doch ganz schön länger dauert
als geplant und man fragt sich wie lange
die Einigung dann hält wenn sie erstmal
da ist und gut ich finde bis zum
gewissenrad ist es unberechenbar wie
geht dieser Krieg weiter und wie geht
wie geht es mit den Energiepreisen
weiter das sind auch Sachen auf die die
Ampel ja nicht hundertprozentig Einfluss
hat und bei der Mehrwertsteuer muss man
sagen sie kehrt so hart das ist das will
ich wirklich überhaupt nicht bestreiten
sie kehrt zurück zu einem die sie vorher
hatte also das ist jetzt nicht so dass
die Ampel das jetzt erhöht sondern sie
macht eine Senkung sie lässt eine
Senkung Auslaufen das ist es ist
trotzdem es trifft Leute hart Tri aber
rückeh zu alterhöhe das ist schon was
anderes als jetzt dass die Ampel sag
erhöen ander
bndkanz das Gegenteil versprochen er hat
versprochen es bleibt bei und wenn jetzt
auf 19 und gleichzeitig her Kü sagt er
will dann die erbschasteuer für die
Unternehmen ran da wünsche ich gute
Reise ich bin froh dass es noch noch
Gastronomen gibt und Restaurants und
Hotels in Deutschland die überhaupt das
Unternehmen vererben wollen in die
nächste Generation dass es noch junge
Leute gibt die es weitermachen wollen
okay also eigentlich ist ja die Frage
Herr küand Herr Lindemann große
Koalition wäre dann die Alternative zu
dem was wir gerade aufgeführt bekommen
keine
gesos sie haben beide große Lust fasse
ich ihre Reaktionen zusammen und sage
dann mit oder ohne Schuldenbremse in
jedem Fall wäre es die ungeliebte große
wie groß ist die Sehnsucht ihrer
Genossen danach mittlerweile wenn man
sich 14% SPD anschaut sie sind in dieser
Ampel quasi von zwei Seiten eingemauert
und könnten sich was einfacheres
wünschen auch als Generalsekretär
vielleicht na ja ich würde mir natürlich
bessere Umfragewerte für meine Partei
wünschen aber das mal beiseite gelassen
das tut jetzt hier gar nicht zur Sache
ich bin auch einfach Demokrat und mache
mir Gedanken dadum wie das in unserer
Demokratie weitergeht das wird eher der
normal Fall in Zukunft sein dass drei
Parteien manchmal auch mehr Regierung
zusammenbilden müssen bin ich jetzt
erfreut über das was ich von unserem
Koalitionspartner gerade gehört habe nee
können Sie sich denken aber ich bin
dafür dass wir eine Demokratie haben in
der Leute wie Herr Lindner und Leute wie
ich zumindest mal für eine Zeit wenn es
die Mehrheiten nicht anders hergeben
zusammen in der Koalition sein müssen
damit die Sachen vorangehen beim
nächsten Mal kämpfe ich leidenschaftlich
dafür dass wir andere Mehrheiten haben
aber ich bin dafür dass es geht weil ich
habe gesehen vor z D Wochen wie doch
hoffentlich wir alle was bei unseren
Nachbarn in den Niederlanden passiert
ist wenn Parteien wegen
haushaltsstreitigkeiten oder weil jemand
sich ein klein karierten Vorteil erhofft
eine Regierung aufkündigen und die
lachenden Dritten sind am Ende die
Rechtsradikalen bei denen jetzt jeder
Zweite in den Niederlanden sagt ich kann
mir vorstellen dass der Typ an der
Spitze der genauso rechtsradikal wie
immer in seiner Geschichte ist dass der
jetzt noch Ministerpräsident wird ich
will sowas nicht in Deutschland und
deswegen möchte ich dass wir als
demokratische Parteien hart in der Sache
streiten aber dass wir es am Ende
zusammen hinkriegen ja und deswegen
sehne ich mich nach keiner großen
Koalition aber danach dass wir zusammen
immer über sowas sprechen können wie wir
so fragen wie Schuldenregel
Weiterentwicklung und ähnliches machen
können das muss möglich sein ganz
zivilisiert gerade in Deutschland mit
unserer Geschichte und unserer
Verantwortung Herr südekum wie sehr
glauben Sie dass das noch zu einen ist
also wir haben im Ohr was Christian
Lindner sagt wir haben im Ohr was Herr
küert für sich und die SPD formuliert
jetzt auch auf dem Parteitag aber auch
überhaupt wir wissen was die Grünen und
eigentlich die gesamte Ampel natürlich
schffen will ist das zu einen in ihren
Augen das weiß ich natürlich nicht ich
hoffe ist dass erm sozusagen die
kurzfristige Lösung da geschaffen wird
ja ich möchte aber sagen die
längerfristige Lösung kann aus meiner
Sicht wirklich nur im Konsens aller
demokratischen Parteien gefunden werden
weil jetzt bei den grundsätzlichen
Reformen kommt es auf die Union an und
die Union muss sich natürlich auch die
Frage stellen wenn sie auch die nächste
Wahl mal gewinnen will mit welchen
Haushalt mit welcher Haushaltssituation
will man dann umgehen weil die Probleme
werden nicht kleiner ja die Haushalte
werden auch in den kommenden Jahren noch
immer stärker unter Druck geraten und
DAF braucht man eine grundsätzliche
Architektur die funktioniert und ich
glaube das gilt für alle Parteien und
deswegen glaube ich der nächste Schritt
also jetzt erstmal kurzfristig muss man
diesen Haushalt 24 realistisch über die
Ziellinie bringen ja und sich jetzt
sozusagen nicht in diesen
kürzungsdiskussionen verlieren die am
Ende nicht funktionieren werden das ist
der erste Schritt und der zweite Schritt
dann quasi ab dem 2 Januar
2024 muss man eine grundsätzliche
Diskussion führen über die
finanzpolitische Architektur und da
hoffe ich dass eben wirklich letztlich
die Ampel und die Union sich auch
verständigen können sei es eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse die Alternative die
vielleicht noch etwas anstlussfähiger
ist ist dass man eben sagt wir machen
ein Sondervermögen klimatransformation
nach dem Vorbild des Sondervermögens für
die Bundeswehr verankn das in der
Verfassung machen ist darüber rechts
sicher und haben darüber dann eben auch
eine wirkliche Planbarkeit was die
Finanzen angeht und kombiniert das
meinetwegen dann mit anderen Reformen
die auch notwendig sind und hat dar
vielleicht ein Kompromiss ob das
realistisch ist weiß ich nicht aber als
Bürger würde ich mir das zumind wünschen
bruchte man auch wieder die Union und
die schüttelt noch den Kopf das haben ja
damals mitgemacht bei der Bundeswehr mit
den
100 und alle anderen Fragen werden wir
am Montag beantworten dann stellen wir
unser neues Grundsatzprogramm vor und
dann können Sie das alles
sehen ein schöner kliffhänger dann
wissen wir aber auf jeden Fall dass sie
es eigentlich abgelehnt haben sich mit
einem solchen Sondereigentum Klima zu
befassen denn es würde das Problem für
die Union ja nicht einfacher machen wir
sind das ja beim Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr ein paar Milliarden sind ab
gerufen irgendwie nur ein Drittel
irgendwie unter Vorbehalt dass damit
jetzt geplant wird es geht also es der
jetzige fun gut wir machen einen Punkt
ich darf mich bedanken für diese
Diskussion am heutigen Abend und gebe
ziemlich hurtig zu Markus Lanz der heute
unter anderem Michael wolfsohn zu Gast
hat wir sehen uns wenn Sie mögen
nächsten Donnerstag wieder 22:15 Uhr
gleiche Stelle neue Zeit nämlich die
angestammte heute ein bisschen später
vielen Dank und bis nächsten Donnerstag
mie noch mal in die Runde einmal
verschluckt entschuldigung das ist jar
[Musik]
furchtbar